[Musique]
passer à la télé a de bons côtés on vous
reconnaît dans la rue vous avez des
admirateurs qui vous témoigne leur amour
sur les réseaux sociaux
mais il existe un revers à cette
médaille et certains candidats de
l'émission l'amour est dans le pré en
ont fait l'amère expérience
en effet plusieurs candidats de
l'émission fait l'objet de harcèlement
de la part de téléspectateurs
malveillants c'est par exemple le cas de
mathieu et alexandre deux candidats qui
se sont rencontrés dans l'émission si
leur histoire a ému des millions
téléspectateurs
le couple a reçu de nombreuses menaces
de mort il nous avait parlé de cette
épreuve dans tpm plj j'ai le courage de
montrer deux garçons sont passés avec la
loi et on a reçu des messages
on va vous châtié on va crucifier
explosé dans l'émission m6 et la
production de l'amour est dans le pré ne
me semble pas préparer les candidats à
la presse si l'émission est populaire il
est évident que les différences exposé à
l'écran font recette mais peuvent aussi
créer des réactions hostiles des menaces
inquiétante et d'une rare violence pour
des candidats livrés à eux mêmes alors
des candidats de l'amour est dans le pré
menacer la production est elle
responsable
évidemment corriger ça m'intéresse pas
je parlais de l'émission et non pas
autour des menaces
bien évidemment vous aurez rectifié de
vous même alors j -louis pour vous la
prod ils sont trop exposés les candidats
de la dre d'entrée le montage caricature
parfois c'est le mes jambes sont pas
caricaturaux mais parfois dans le
montage comme sur ce couple là que vous
avez un mitri à juste titre parfois il y
avait des éléments qui pouvaient induire
de la caricature et qui m'ont gêné
d'autre part après ils ne sont pas assez
suivi c'est après que c'est dangereux
parce qu'ils sont surexposés rixe était
caricatural
ce couple homosexuel certains éléments
de montage parfois sur certaines scènes
ne seraient pas d'accord sans une
seconde mais moi j'ai trouvé que c'est
parfois car on n'a pas le temps mais moi
j'ai trouvé que c'est parfois
caricaturales et c'est vrai qu'après
après ils ne sont pas à ces sujets on a
lavé par les rebelles quelques temps on
disait que les productions quand on fait
quelque chose on exposer que ce soit de
la télé-réalité ou des jeux on ne parle
pas avant et après de la gestion de la
mise à la vente soit même à travers les
réseaux etc
c'est ça je pense que il faut
aujourd'hui que les productions
préviennent de ce qui peut arriver c'est
très bien qu'on conquis et tout ça mais
il faut juste les préparer à ce qui est
des gens derrière les critiques les
mails et les menaces mais c'est
malheureusement 25 ans sociaux c'est
plus très nouveau donc
faut préparer c'est que la production
doit préparer à venir sk les a prévenus
caisse qwiki production à la baisse des
avoirs des insultes des tu peux pas dire
ça on regarde le doigt à l'époque y
avait pas de réseaux sociaux on nous a
pas préparé à ce qu'on nous dise on a
été menacé de mort on nous envoyait des
lettres de menace tout ça on est pas
prêt à ça il faut quand même si faut
qu'un sixième ça arrive et jp il y en a
eu d'autres
dans chaque production maintenant il ya
des chips et écologique pour les
candidats à ballon avant pendant et
après cela le problème c'est pas la
sauter la production qui reste hélas
hélas je pense que les menaces de mort
de toute façon s'ils l'avaient fait les
murs qu'ils fassent l'émission ou pas il
les aurait une ville ça qui est grave
c'est des gens avec une wii ont fait que
ont des complexes totalement
l'homophobie et voilà et au contraire je
suis très contente et bravo m6 prenait
banfora sur la dans la prochaine saison
il ya une jeune femme qui rit et
lesbiennes qui va faire entre oui si
c'est pour les aînés j'ai pas dit que
cette jeune héroïne il faut préparer
juste les candidats dans toutes les
prendre maintenant surtout que
bizarrement les autres candidats n'ont
pas des menaces de mort dénonce pascal
bats c'est vraiment un couple homosexuel
cadets mais c'est parce que
malheureusement on reconnaît dans un
pays anglophone
c'est cette belle folie mais c'est ça
qu'il faut délaisser sa version elle
peut pas lutter elle toute seule contre
l'homophobie offre sauf qu'ils sont
exposés magali on veut pas dire d'un
côté oui il faut mettre ça en avant les
meilleurs mais je vais raccrocher aux
productions de se mettre en avant
jusque sur koh lanta ya des candidats
qui n'étaient pas valables qui se sont
aussi retrouvés menacé de mort c'est
juste la société un sound
ces malades sur les réseaux sociaux
exactement sont à l'arrêt tant les
réseaux sociaux sont les rideaux
en avant on a des gens à l'homophobie et
[Musique]
à 14000 il faut porter plainte à chaque
fois mais bon est-ce que la production
prend en charge les frais de justice on
y lit à 17 je lui dis à disposition non
ça peut arriver qu'ils les aident
juridiquement